everybody welcome cater brides on
clapping I'll welcome this week we're
very excited we have the whole cast of
the show TV let's show teachers here
with us they're all named Katie or
Katherine or Kate this is Kate Lambert
this is your last of colleton but it's
Katie
you know the lassie weren't give it to
you ten seconds in I've already screw
this all okay and then in the back we
have all the other Katie's and
Catherine's who are gonna be joining us
later and we're gonna play a little
we're gonna play a little Mario Kart but
here's the thing we're gonna raise the
stakes all right wait we have a guest I
wanted to make it fun for every Owen
bets here of course Beth and Jason Emily
creeper we know characters all right
that's enough
you've had your mother you've had your
moment you're here every week all right
jelly belly soon as this thing is called
bean boozled well done on the name Jelly
Belly and what it is is apparently you
know how Jelly Belly's tastes exactly
like whatever it is you have time and
it's like yeah
buttered popcorn and by the way fu Jelly
Belly terrible idea of building popcorn
but yo guys come up with disgusting
flavors and they came with a little
spinner they sent us this thing so
here's what happens
person in last place has to do a little
spinner thing and then you will either
get randomly a delicious jelly belly or
one that tastes like garbage water no
like so here yes just give you an
example in this test tube here these are
not my pills I've already taken all my
pills today I know it seems like I
haven't but we have spoiled milk and
coconut also I didn't write that because
you could actually read it I had a
serial killer handwriting and this one
is a banana smoothie shirt but also dead
fish and strawberry although I think it
doesn't I think that she meant to say I
good for your skin I think that's a
strawberry banana smoothie I don't think
it's dead fish and strawberry all right
why would they make dead fish and
strawberry maybe the fish ate
strawberries before I died give it up
Lambert all right here we go so we're
gonna put a little Mario Kart here also
teachers from
last Wednesday congratulations ladies
clap yourselves but who cares and it's
on every Wednesday at 10:30 9:30 for you
mountain people essential on TV land so
watch it nasty bad diddly why are you
apologizing all right here we go
Kate has picked baby peach it's the
pacifier right not the gum she thought
it was bubble gum but she got bean
boozled right yeah see how many times I
could say bean boozled Katie what do you
would eat with your chest
I chose it looks like the sexy baby holy
[ __ ]
okay here we go I'm gonna go uh you know
what two babies how about let's get a
man in here I mean with a shell I don't
know what any of this stuff is so I just
hit the but hit a a lot yeah I know I've
never played this before okay all right
what Sears we're gonna do we're gonna
hold it this way and you drive like this
you actually do drive like this just
yeah yeah it's crazy town and I don't
actually know I think two is gas and
this is slot we're gonna figure it out
together
wait is this am i any other thing I know
I'm not I mean I'm not you're the one
okay
so Kate is bottom left
Katie's upper right and I'm the weird
turtle all right let's just start with
the basics
yeah the old mushroom Cup as they say I
mean just a heads up I was a theater kid
so is that a brag or an apology
I can't I was a period would it be great
if I was a gameshark though and I just
pretended like I hadn't played any of
these before you're uh yeah the color of
money yeah totally I don't know
Mario is all of us we're at Mario's and
everything every man fresh every
mustache man I there's also other people
who aren't us playing in this thing
ladies is a peanut gallery predictions
predictions on who's gonna win
okay who's that Kop Kop Kop and outside
here we go
okay okay by the way I show the camera
your dope shoes yeah she's putting the
rest of you to shame really
her style is really on your UK you would
be like the cool teacher right yeah I
mean I know kind of none of you or the
cool
Chelsea snaps OC snap is very honest
right Katie's in her mind she's cool
she's gonna come back with new limbs
there we go we're all gonna come back
with no forehead
hashtag life goal that was me this is
gonna be a dream I'll never stop playing
this game and a nightmare when we hit
the Jelly Bellies Bowser for the Wade
Thank You assassin 1999 that's the
square that's the squid-like driving in
LA
why is there PJ PJ M's just here at kiss
George Lacey drops by any mic cuz there
are ladies here no offense Beth I'm
sorry you should be like you feel lucky
they put turn doesn't stock you turn
okay yes the floor recognizes the peanut
gallery go does moving the remote
actually do anything it does not the big
dinner plate one but the other ones okay
you're gonna do very well
it does help that's a lie I've been
moving it a lot and I think I'm just
moving forward oh wait are you guys are
actually doing really well I'm not even
I'm not lying and I normally lie that's
great see this is
they say your fur this isn't a roni it's
a race the road
yeah there's horns there's people
watching both yeah yeah athlete duck
hunt I ever played duck I know what I'm
gonna say something I'm gonna say
something it's gonna make you a little
bit upset are you ready for this
did you know did you know that one that
you might not care cuz I'm a huge earner
is that the other person if you plug
another controller the other person
could control the Ducks yes isn't that
crazy
yes it's a true thing that's right oh
this is such a dream that's right it's a
race I gave the engineer I don't think
we I don't think we have actually ever
played super super trash oh we played
yeah we played a comic-con with the
playmates yeah well yep come play with
playmates came in that's right that's
right guys okay here's a game that was
for real here's the thing Katie here's
the thing well here's it also want to
bring this up I want to bring this up I
want to bring this up each you can also
get a good jelly belly yeah you
understand what I'm saying this might be
a treat for ya this maybe this could be
a little treat alright the spinner goes
to baby blue or berry blue or toothpaste
all right I just don't know which one it
is I had to face this morning little bit
clean I'm sorry you have to have fresh
breath now I'm so sorry alright two more
ladies get over here yeah luigi is
always overlooked yeah not for me he
said he's the kinder of the tube Mario
sick today
hey all right ladies all right here we
go I don't know either I don't know
either
we're all gonna find out together next
race oh you know what
wait I think we're a little quick let's
guy you actually have this Sebastian
because we are trapped in the mushroom
cup we don't care about that
Katherine Renee Thomas me and Jesus
Christ what does it matter
Kayla Barlow yes good job I did look at
my sheet that's okay but it doesn't have
any faces on it true it doesn't there we
go all right it's all bang level is what
it is all right here we go so hit a wait
no I don't ever listen to me I'm a
terrible person
I don't know we do this and then we do
this okay now you're back you had a all
right all right you're down there I'm
Caitlin is down lower left Katherine's
upper right right now you guys okay you
got that dude I think I want this is
this little baby face is mega creepy oh
she did the yeah the reason why Katie
did the blue jelly belly first is cuz
there was a spinner I don't know I
didn't show that properly there's a
little spinner here she spun it
it wasn't just random you know I'm here
yeah girl do you what do you what do you
side of it what oh my god ladies please
actually you know what when I used to
live in New York I heard no I have those
now no I was walking in front of two
women who were talking girls really
looks okay yeah I was a boy as I am now
and they were talking and I overheard
them talking about dsls but they were
saying there she was like what kind of
Batman was his lips and and she goes I
don't know she's like it was kind of
like like a Clooney and she goes oh I
prefer a Val Kilmer and I was like what
is happening is this real life is this
fantasy on the landslide you know
I don't even know I wanted to turn
around ass but then I'm that guy and
then I'm on a blog and that's a terrible
thing I'm gonna do I'm going baby Mario
because that hat doesn't that doesn't
fit him and he looks real cute in it
there's a song about a hat that don't I
know
and so now we're picking out what kind
of car yeah you know I'm going flower
you do what you want you know I like to
bright in the world it's just me you
have allergies I apologize just little
pink cards I think what the katydids all
imagine we'll all drive one day okay
like a gag all these six it with the
purple wheels oh you all have separate
ones or one jot or one giant one you're
just gonna cream okay yeah we live in a
house in Malibu with pink bus please
it's the boob god damnit try to be cool
by the time you finish saying malibu
you're too old to live there don't play
like your solo I call it the ace deuce
not Ann Arbor it's a snooze juice
my dad would I would say a two squared
and it would drive me crazy cuz I'm like
that's too many A's did he go like a 2
squared way to be like a - what are we
doing let's get racing yeah just keep
you got a yeah yeah yeah there we go
go blue wait oh my god no teams
oh we're trapped in a hellish alright
here we go alright okay now what would
you rate your Mario Kart level as
mushroom mushroom okay yeah how about
the wall you guys like the waterpark
look at those moves you got she's like
do I love the waterpark
Justin timber everyone is saying one
pound fish in the thing I don't know
what that means I don't know oh it's all
spammer ooh go Beth go
Hagar's gave me today welcome vanilla
cola
oh my god you're right what is going no
one knows well what's your position on
flavored colas oh my gosh
you know I'm not a big coal a person
what but I think that you know but if
you are you know if you are you should
have options you know what I mean you
know what I like the oven open Kaitlyn
what about you don't worry about the
racing because of the I'm from Michigan
so we say pick this is this and this oh
it's at number two number two button oh
yeah I should hop to audience are
dancing so I went to a camp a news story
and I was like I should say soda because
that's what the East Coaster saying no
be true to yourself choose your own
finger will o be true to yourself yeah
so much peer pressure when I lived in
New York its soda no so does it kind of
water thank you yeah it's soda no so
does the type of jerk thank you it's pop
let's just all agree that it's probably
bad for you so what's your opinion on
unflavored sodas look you know live and
live and let live I saw the revenant
last night and now human life means
nothing to me human life means nothing
we're all just flowers and wind be
grateful for the little things like
flavored soda it's you know he was
getting mauled by there I bet you leo
dekap really wish for a vanilla flavored
so I don't say the rest of the words the
whole thing but you know yeah you know
it's leo dekap do serves and ask you
know is perform you know in the rest
okay I will say I have a lot of a lot of
bees for the Oscars this year but I do
dings I agree he's put in the work he
deserves a prize that's given out
basically arbitrarily and that's nothing
right to anybody only the people who
have no souls you know I mean you know
what like here's the thing I feel like
with my B's like that you just got to
put them in a cold room and just feel
what you're feeling in a cold room you
know I did it backwards I don't know my
question I maybe you should um my
husband is at home and he's so ashamed I
know that no he's proud he's so proud
he's proud cuz you're playing you know
what you're a winner cuz you're playing
their winner cuz you're on the field
that's not true in any game including
I'm actually losing very badly out
you're 11 that's like just let me to the
park you know what they say yeah 11th is
10th plate fresh plate I don't know I
think I'm 11 Oh
oh my oh you're you're uh you're 12
because I looked over and you're 12 it
was that was math that was uh that was
extra math my body has absorbed a shot
math out of your mouth well that my body
hasn't absorbed yet so if you were a
superhero you could sell that
what would your your mess out of the
mouth shooting named me um sad boy I'm
losing all the math man yeah I didn't
see it spoilers spoilers
I know it came out 93 but I I by the way
hate when people are like oh my god I
haven't seen it oh my god oh my god yeah
it's the wire it came it's like it was
shot in 4:3 I was wearing baggy pants
extremely old half actors are dead yeah
oh my god come on okay well I know I
won't be BAM bean bean boozled this time
this is the cast of teachers all six of
them and they're also an amazing improv
group called the katydids you can follow
them at the Katy dates with the K I
can't see why CICS and teachers is on
every Wednesday night at 10:30 on TV
Lang who lost to finish are you are you
loser are you a winner is the question
the answer is your loser spin if you
don't want to watch me favorite guy barf
barf barf it's Pete oh it is Peter Guber
that's peach or barf so the deal is half
of these tastes like Pete alright so I
think it's that the bloody looking one
right there right does that look okay
that's it all right
like this I'm leaning back is I'm
burping necks I'm afraid son of a [ __ ]
all right
oh here it will be in about ten minutes
but she has another one all right coming
in a little hot with a full head set oh
yeah yeah hold on yeah I need to quit my
Call of Duty game to get in on this
defeat of my own people
Yeah right exactly exactly hold on wait
hold on I'll get it set up yes we want
to kill yes you want to quit
hey vanilla Cola what's up I hope you
enjoyed our little that's why you know I
was saying it for the chat the flaming
coal is didn't just come off the dome as
much you know how are you guys at
wrapping by the way moonlight is rappers
you should daylight is rappers they make
way more money than us in common I know
yeah you're right
no you're not a [ __ ] so you want to
kind of point it I think you you're blue
okay blue your your pink your pink and
pink your pink yep you got it that baby
so you're you're you're down there this
is your character you're pointing with
this that's gonna choose your character
actually with this girl Kate Friedman
everyone and Kate O'Brien did it we did
it didn't even have to look at the blue
card that had nothing on it can I have
this one that's like yes that mold no
guys yeah wait no that's her your she's
Wendy yeah she's okay I'm chosen to do
you want to be Roy wait you guys oh my
god peanut gallery who should I be
peanut gallery not help your prose is
illustrated well done which that
snaggletooth this guy's look
snaggletooth e oh he's great fair enough
flower on the back door is a distraction
oh my god that's a strategy girl [ __ ]
that I'm going playing cuz planes fly
fast and I want to go fast okay that's
right just just said you just hit random
stuff doesn't all right here we go more
moisture all right let's go just one
step crazier okay let's go to toe too
hard oh [ __ ]
that's for real proper response to toe
ah quick question I know our teacher
started as a web series yeah how did the
idea come about cuz you guys for people
who don't know it's a they're all
elementary school teachers and they're
all effed up but in a great funny way
yeah so how did it come out fun funky
fresh way it is three X so it started
because a friend of ours said that we
all looks like elementary school
teachers and we shop until their log
what is that the only requirement to be
a kinder yahren school teacher there is
education those oh sorry okay here we go
I'm not this I'm not being a good host
here we go you drive like this yeah and
you hit 200 to get there you go
I'm on yet later skills I my back to the
races oh yeah I've been here before and
I said before I'm a price and fed up
teachers is interesting you should watch
it it's on Wednesday nights at 10:30 ITT
life unless you live in the mountains in
which case you're in central time and
that's a nine thirty of you in time on
the old TV line you can also watch all
the episodes of which there's only been
one so far but I'm guessing there's many
more will be more tvline.com slash so it
shows slash teachers not don't listen
real show this other girl who didn't
know what to do I'll just hold it down
hold it down okay you just drive like
this it's just constantly put in
terrible my worst worst driver ever oh
my gosh which means you're second best
driver in LA that's a yes thank you Beth
that's the link I just said but it's in
clickable form okay that's right you
don't live in the mountains f Bryson
that's great you don't want to live in
the mountains again we were just talking
about the revenue that makes me not want
to move their bounds more wildlife and
does not make me want to have a bear as
a pet either which I did looks
freakishly yeah fricassee rapey also
raping he slept in inside of a horse got
it and crawled inside the bear grylls
did too and nobody was bitching about
that yeah my friend is actually Bear
Grylls assistant and does all that stuff
that's crazy what is that one it's
exactly like the show intensive real
life I've never met Bear Grylls but my
friend is intense about partying that
guy I mean he sucks down Miller lights
like Bear Grylls sucks out sheep
eyeballs my whole family okay she by
those part of the beer part okay wait
where are you from from Nebraska give it
up I have a home guess
I read a couple of BIOS written in the
third person let me give you the facts
about Omaha cuz it's a great city
oh okay I didn't ask you
number one zoo in the country oh yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa yes man the San
Diego Zoo we beat out see how is that
possible do they give you an animal
every time you leave yeah we have a
desert don't we have an indoor aquarium
we have a sky fari well you break up you
go up in the sky on a safari yeah I
think you were just really high this is
all a dream I think you're really hiding
with you a pet store you like it since I
got an open field and imagine you're
upside down Kate no it's a sky fari okay
that's I got one time O'Brien went to
the Renaissance Fair and took an edible
and she died in a wheelchair good how
many giant turkey like that one and I
watched the joust all by myself
cut Sousa painting that's crazy I can't
do the edible thing because it makes me
I get like this like whatever that I
just did is how I get but but that
sounds amazing and I will say really
what I would love to do some shrooms at
some point and walk through the ARB in
Ann Arbor yes great Thomas isn't
listening machine it's a giant it's like
imagine the Nebraska zoo but with no
walls and no animals and it's in an
arbor every summer every so that's
that's right that's right
in high school I declined to be in that
pioneer Stadium
oh you are straight close awesome
Stadium although yeah I was like the
sound guy
yeah I'm family in an hour
you mean like the guys who smash fruit
like a Mary Therese Gallagher no that's
not like a Gallagher's a person whose
last that would be read last of the game
buddy lastly a game but first in our
heart but then also last our minds cuz
you did lose the game that's true and
thank you for playing along all right so
just spin the old spinner oh that does
it come on there's on the surface yeah
oh yeah that's a good spin coconut or
baby wipes no wait a second I also give
you a cent
and wait a second they also sent these
I'm guessing special flavors just to us
cuz they're in these weird test tubes
would you rather have coconut and
spoiled milk or coconut baby wipes yeah
I mean what do you want to risk the
spoiled ugly baby I would like to try as
many as people killed you're insane all
right here we go let's just do the baby
wipes cuz I feel like I'd rather have a
baby wipe in my shirt yeah I mean I do
anything don't give me any of ya know
this is the white ones oh the white the
white ones yeah that's either coconut or
baby wipes
you don't know coconut or baby wait okay
can you just anthony bourdain this very
quickly take us through your what your
palate is feeling and experiencing right
now it is it is soft it is sweet it is
new newborn and it is it's got hints of
powder it's just like it's like it's
like oh my god wake up breathe in their
face - that's amazing that's
unbelievable
it's jeez that is the worst thing ever
in history
it really does so I'm gonna say well
done Jelly Belly yes well done well done
Jelly Belly everyone right all right do
you guys want to keep playing Mario or
play a new game
I was hoping now for this I'm gonna need
three ladies what's that you can vomit
I'm gonna need a real ladies over here
Andrew Zimmern
that's your gangsta you're right it's
more of an Andrew Zimmer than a Anthony
Bourdain
Andrew Zimmern is a different food guy
who eats yeah each Bizarre Foods
exactly oh here we go so I asked for the
Anthony Bourdain those and you gave it
to me which I appreciate we do it's
right here here we are now wait a second
let's go to close software please tell
everyone you highlight let's go down you
start while I'm fixing this stuff a
highlight of shooting a highlight so far
shooting the teachers series which you
could find on TV land why are we what
why are we doing why are we updating oh
my god oh so this will be good so a
highlight show for how many episodes you
guys shot we shot ten episodes that's so
many episodes are you exhausted um no
cuz we shot them over so you were
shouldn't say this is highlight but the
highlight was walking into our personal
trailers when we all scream like hyenas
wait the first day they don't make you
share a trailer do they no but that was
the coolest part you all got your
trailer it was just one highlight then
it did keep getting how did the trailer
this is my nightmare this is the worst
thing that's ever happening in this how
does your trailer compare how do we try
to compare your apartment because my
office is literally six times the size
of my apartment did you want to move
into the trailer the appliances were
nice maybe like treating your right got
that sweet tea deal and Keshi SHhhh it's
all those Dick Van Dyke reruns they're
making
scratch on yeah it's like us with all
the Tyler Perry shows and the the Big
Bang Theory on TV yes it's all that Big
Bang run off money yeah it's quite quite
delicious
here's a fun fact about the trailers I'm
not gonna say who but two of our members
okay well we know one of the members
okay
collagen what the hell Jesus poker with
you all right what is it one Katie and
who else what happened now let's hear it
now you have to say it well I'm just
gonna say it there were two two two
Taylor saw a lot of back to back they
literally were back to back you know
like the way the way it was that's like
how I feel like you guys are two
detectives like how detectives are crap
like in the bathroom like let's do you
ready all right let's do at least you
made at least you made use of the time
at least you made use the time pretty
nervous right what was the other poster
what's the second place story so um okay
Thomas and I lived together for three
years when we lived in Chicago and Kate
how much they both had like fairly
healthy diets doesn't sound like it
nothing all you guys are just eating
just a lot of soft fruits
okay sorry and so we like both of us
like you know on occasion like very much
about women on occasion oh my gosh thank
you that on occasion on occasion sure on
occasion yeah so keep going one time I
took a really big dump and it clogged
the toilet but I forgot to text her and
tell her they call you toilet I had to
run out really fast I didn't have time
bring like a death-row time to you it's
a gift for us yeah this is like a jelly
belly for my mind was happy
it gets worse so she could house and she
also had to take a dump so she just like
good good that's real friends wait wait
what's the first poo though and I hate
to go deep on this but I'm going to
because I'm investing I'm like Stone
Phillips about poop investigative
journalist um what's it with yours was
it the shape or the volume because okay
okay okay so kind of Weisberger
sometimes it can just happen to believe
that jelly belly game anymore
essentially their poop shook hands yeah
high five
Oh God and then a maintenance guy to
come over and I was just sitting in the
living room by myself and this guy comes
in and it's like I just was so
humiliated because I thought maybe he
thought I made all that you should have
been proud everyone stop anything
emergency all I'll kill you all find
your bodies all right here we go we're
gonna go players perfect all right now
Ivan points a person somebody I want the
guy who looks like mr. Feeny mr. Feeny
yeah from Boy Meets World
oh that guy I think I'm a guy with the
great goatee hey that's me by the way
that's supposed to be me watching a
budget it's like I'm watching a kids at
a Star Wars matinee shows the guy with
the strong eyebrows guy there we go the
guy with the face oh you know what now I
have stuff that was my screw-up sorry
everybody everyone do it again do it
again I'm gonna be a guy with a goatee
aka me
great good team oh here we go Chile
Falls approve story when I was little I
clogged the toilet so much my mom and to
make me sign a sign that said BM that
way she was left that takes the day well
done but you know it's smart on your mom
by the way you got a smart mom
alright that's gonna tell us how to play
but I'm also gonna tell you how to play
I'm gonna run away and you just gotta
catch me hold your thing sideways and
you're gonna run see you run with it
thing close you run with the d-pad okay
or the do keypad I guess if I'm talking
to you guys and then two tackles but
don't where you're never gonna get that
I'm in my frickin self
yes mr. Feeny fine as I crush it can
ineffectually with my sister's babies Oh
steel pillow the habit of one of my
friends to where he was and this he was
a child so let's all just relax someone
just asked what's a BM so we should
probably tell them it's Batman yes this
is educational as well yeah don't worry
a primarily primarily educational
program but yeah and he was sitting
behind his sister the tub and it was
like bubble bubble and he was 32 so you
should have been all right you two
minutes and 30 seconds of catching all
right ladies this is about communication
is about teamwork you guys are on the
show teachers airing at 10:30 every
Wednesday night so you should be able to
catch me see I worked that plug animal
by the way if you guys have any other
two stories Beth won't ban you for the
poo story just this one time
don't don't abuse my don't abuse my gift
later / interpret I'm looking on here oh
yes you don't know where I am
come on try to follow me
that's it this way oh and also it tells
you how close you are you saying yardage
there okay thank you
oh oh look there's a camera me too I'm
in the green area and I'm getting closer
oh my God where is he oh god where is it
oh god oh my god this is why we would be
terrible guys where is he where is he oh
my god I don't hear anybody
communicating they're now heading to the
right wake sign now looking at the right
iris farther and further away from you
I'm drunk we're gonna go it's getting
I'm getting bigger
okay wait I started to buy my even look
at the screen at this this is you guys
heading towards our tree wait you guys
I'm getting okay close I'm here the red
Twitter I mean girl that's you I see
someone this is you guys trying to find
a polymer you need to know I saw I
distinctly saw a man with the red hats
you know okay you guys have any closer
we're gonna close there 20 yards to okay
down here heard I'm not even I'm getting
further okay wait hold on oh man excuse
me
Lambert I felt by the view no catch what
you all got to do the Jelly Belly
they're just spin the world beautiful
[Applause]
we did it alright ladies you know what
should we just do that you just pick out
the thing we don't want to finish we'll
do after the fact I don't know no one
knows wait okay wait we got a green is
lime or lawn clippings alright I'll do
that
Oh juicy Oh what this is juicy pear of
boogers going hard already these respect
from earlier no there no math right I
just see I have a glandular problem ah
yeah that's chocolate pudding or canned
dog food
I think I've eaten I get into about
happy just salty what how about two
chumps give us two chunks okay I don't
know okay
that's ugly bugger said well we know we
now know kiddies never eat their own
boogers there we go now why you oh god
what have you are you had so many Jews
oh you want water why God's green eyes
lawn clippings or lime this is gonna be
gross but can I smell it yeah Oh oh
goodness oh goodness
well do it on camera you know you know
it smells like it smells like burnt
carpet that is so sick oh my god oh wait
yeah we drink why you can drink water
you could drink you know why you're in
my house you could drink water
I mean don't use the toilet though I've
heard some stories wait what did you get
did you get that I think it was lying
but it but it didn't taste Lambert lime
hook it up what have you guys I had dog
food it was disgusting
really it was I don't know man dolphins
pretty good yeah prescription hills yeah
you've taken your dog's pills no it's a
brand oh okay because that's a different
conversation she only shares
prescriptions with anims yeah I was
gonna say yeah I've taken my dog's pills
and they are amazing I have a shiny coat
once I when I was 13 I act I was I had a
headache and I went to the cupboard and
I'm sorry sleep feeding my dog his
epaulet Hubbard and I got I got it down
and it's like Oh Tylenol it'll have a
headache and then it turns out it was
actually my dog Zeppelin see medication
it was dog but all they shouldn't name
it which is okay like people take it
just not in huge quantities like humans
okay I get it it's just like it's like a
Flintstones chewable thing versus
another thing I'm a doctor
I'm a dog ladies you want to complain
my goodness I gotta say you know yeah
it's Doug I will say that way Katie took
one for the team but then again if you
had caught me it wouldn't have n a
problem all right who wants to be runner
this time oh you want to no no I can't I
can't see where you are at yes
Aaron you swole take off your shirt
there's a lot of rashes happening here a
lot of Raschi hairy things going on I'm
not I'm just if you want to play jelly
belly with human bodies
yeah they starred themselves jerk dog on
Santa's lap that's how Christmas works
by the way that's not how Christmas
works I just want to point that out okay
let's play same same level or different
level different levels different okay
hope you're ready for a little mud ready
to get dirty in the wine all right so
you're gonna you're gonna run around
with this thing right and then you've
you get close you you are just looking
at this and you're moving you're using
this to run around this thing that's all
you need so press let's press both
triggers here nasty that's so sexy
nothing more sexy than what Ashley's I
wish Conan would just come something in
a frame right now and put him into a
headlock meets fear Conan already pushed
me into a bunch of boxes today so I'm
hoping I also there's a camera this is a
camera it's alright let's go let's go
it's communicate let's get in that mud
let's get in that mud here we go see to
Freeman you can see you can see where we
are
and I can see on here where you guys are
- yeah you should just look at the game
not even look at the stuff of the big
tea Oh 15 yards 13 oh no no Kate O'Brien
no relation to Conan O'Brien correct
correct but I used to lie in high school
and say that I was oh how did that go it
got me some more friends I'm not gonna
lie maybe hilarious they're like oh now
we're not going to talk to you I know
right
was that affiliation Conan should die he
will one day so will we all life is a
total bonus everybody try to bring
everybody down that's you a little bit
you know it's a we got appreciate the
good moments like when the cast of
teachers whose show airs at 10:30 on TV
land every Wednesday night comes by yeah
this is why you know as we only get you
let's say 80 some birthday's on this on
this earth I know I she's a green green
headed to blue I'm in the mud I'm in the
mud I'm running I'm first pika-pika
what's up has a gun my Oh Slayer Darth
asked a great question maybe for the
peanut gallery coolest funniest teacher
you guys have ever had oh my gosh who
wants to start let's see I had I had a
teacher in high school mr. Norgren and
he was in charge of all the data there
the like sound and tech stuff in the
auditorium and savino's Oh class like a
real college class in lecture to us
about world history but anytime you
would talk about one group invading
another group like you know he'd be like
and then the Mongols came over the hill
and what blocks cutters and he yelled
box cutters so like when the British
came to America and it's a the
Revolution I was like yep and then the
Brits came walks covers and then this
one girl in my grade
walked off the edge of senior prom
fashion show oh no she was really nice
and she walked into the orchestra pit
but mr. Norgren in class today oh yeah
do over and over again in like slo-mo
I'm sorry Lara did he go what was
amazing
okay best funniest teacher funny yet oh
here's to by the way how we did there's
what she went and I thought I had you
good oh Jesus it was a real sad girl
I just look I just followed her that's
where we had our chance it was close
this is a great game and I had a lot of
watches you're about to have some more
fun we're gonna do the Jelly Bellies I
knew I prefer to use the spinner let
fate decide I'll to boogers or it could
be juicy pear which is what I call my
boogers okay oh girl shake caramel corn
it's like thing Oh what do they do there
oh man I think it's in here
oh is it this is fun yeah I gotta say
man the Booker thing is super weird oh I
feel like those maybe have the texture
of a booger - yeah why see it's like one
of those boogers I don't want to get too
gross but I call it a snapback when it's
like in the back of there you just go
I have to the back you know it's what it
is that's why I got it I got a dangler
that a snapback oh it was looks bad it
really tastes great garbs licorice or
skunk spray well I hate black licorice
so this is the unpleasant and also
garbage also garbage all right you guys
want to play you guys stay here okay
play another game it's gonna be called
now do you or do you not this is the one
question mask you believe in ghosts yes
this conversation all right yeah go stay
there you're on camera now you're coming
now you're off camera aren't you on a TV
show parlo god damn all right we're
gonna play once your glutes your ghost
story Barlow I do you want to see me
you're gonna play this after this all
right all right everybody do that thing
where they point with the thing to the
thing and choose a person to person
that's right I don't know who Alpha
Massacre nice sloth emoticons so many
sloths guys I think the sloths of the
new Lowell cats you know Jessie could
also you you can also use this thing
wait let's see all right oh wait you
know what hold on I'm gonna help ya I'm
good I'm just gonna pick everybody you
do you want to be the who wants to be
the ghost all right she said that very
quickly all right you just hit a and
then working it I'm gonna just select
this guy and you're gonna be his name
right
here we go you get to be cozy oh you get
to be Oh what's happening yeah see oh
there's a little can you Gramps I love
you Gramps is soon to be us so it's like
he's a pre ghost
perhaps craps Aroo all right yes Krabs
what is going on over there ladies all
right here's the game the game is Kate
is the ghost you're gonna be invisible
so you look on this thing and we are
going to try to buy okay when she gets
close [ __ ] vibrates and it vibrates the
closer she is very much so very much so
only this is gonna be way better than
that shitty movie okay and uh we shine
our flashlights honor okay okay and I
think you get to hit the flash though
with the old two but okay so you look at
the gamepad screen there okay okay okay
how do we catch all right if we fire her
it'll shake let's raise the stakes you
ready for these stakes to be raised
yes if we lose we each do Jellybelly if
we get her she does three dead in a
ghostly voice this is gonna go great
I leave the gamepad screen hit both
triggers here it dies I'm sure the case
of copyright infringement okay get ready
egg with oven mitts yeah
[Music]
this is really really naughty is it oh
I'm sorry you press one to turn your
flashlight on yeah yeah all right and
then also there will be bad boys it's a
weird horrifying boy's eye there's also
like batteries you can get your
flashlight will run down so be careful
boo you know what solid wills Oh solid
well no one makes a makes a good point
Jelly Belly a viewers choice okay good
all right here we go I'm red I'm upper
I'm upper right weight grams I'm green
remember it's gonna vibrate when it gets
close to you and by it I mean her by her
I mean cake oh kudos says this game is
fun but it gets so stressful it does get
I'm freaking out anybody vibrate yeah I
mean wait are we both where is she do I
capture at your library
yeah you just got to go touch him and
then they go - that's it oh that's it
she says oh she has to get she can get
us - no that's the whole thing she's
really close we can for example where
did watch your back watch your back
I feel it I feel it watch your back Oh
God and then wait how do I get another
giant main paints as I'm vibrating as
well too much caffeine you're welcome
buddy only one coffee a day that's just
that robot helper oh no oh you get the
battery down there if you're out Oh
I can't handle this too much alright you
can shine your light and revive us okay
I'm here oh there there
oh yes I back up back oh you're gay you
burped you get the ghost no I got you
back
I got a green back green you're back I'm
back you're back
Jesus oh I'm sorry I was treating
walking head in the comments this is
horrific says oh so mister yeah
oh they're close too close to me Burnham
Oh God Oh Bert you gotta better go the
one hurting the crap on here alright
we're back
Oh Oh get up get her I know how do you
burn any burner
yeah but the light I mean you've got to
shine the light on her like that Rolling
Stones song about getting ghost shine a
light Jesus here we go a battery full
power mofo here we go where you at ghost
were you at ghost II can't wait by the
way for new Ghostbusters all ladies you
know you know your escape for me you
know who's gonna want to be the ghost
Kate Lambert's don't give a [ __ ] I gotta
get out of here scared people come on
come on provide provide four by five
revive revive revive revive you're back
you're back
I'll revive oh oh oh Kim oh man my my
lights almost done though
wait provider you just go in Rebecca are
you I'm still confused as to how you
actually get her you just shine early
yeah oh my god she's always saying oh my
gosh she's good afternoon jelly
back yes please here we go here we go oh
oh here we go yeah
keep it tight check the corners up in
there up in there I'm going for that
battery go for that battery my name is
healthy I know it's so but it's taking
years off my life I'm so close to weight
the over here alright ready let me get
my pallet ready I don't know why I'm
doing this big ceeze more dramatic all
right here we go
are you yeah yes Berger watch I more
stuff like this watch teachers 10 30s a
Wednesday nights at TV land all right
they want you to black one of the black
ones which is licorice or skunk spray so
rotten it's garlic butter at the bottom
of garbage you guys wait where'd it go
where'd it go you want to smell your
weight we got uh okay we got tutti
frutti or stinky socks that's when we
haven't done before we did moldy cheese
needed barf
buttered popcorn or rotten egg Oh white
someone's saying white all right what
you want to try buttered popcorn rotten
egg sure good a buttered popcorn
one little yellow could be butter
popcorn oh so delicious it's a good
pocket and then one more I'll eat it hey
butt licker 14 mom I told you when use
the butt licker handle I know it's you
right
alright and then I know just try another
who cares okay I'm gonna do the blue so
this could be either berry blue or
toothpaste
alright there we go and you know what
you need it after this go yeah you made
it alright other dudes get in here now
same same rules apply same rules apply
if we get the ghost they do three if we
if we we lose we do one or do we each do
three this might be the last game it
might be one more game I think we got a
I'm gonna I want to bust out the dead
fish and strawberry you have to do the
rest are we gonna do a different we're
doing a different layout layout here
we've all seen that layout we've done it
big batteries at some point no I do so
you are just looking at this yourself
yes and then you know peaking peloton
and then you you'll wanna run you could
see us and you just need to touch us and
then you've grabbed how do I touch you
just running into us okay and then we
need to shine with hitting the one
button we flashlight now you move like
there this guy's saying like raise the
roof or yeah oh yeah we don't care about
this wait what what are you wondering
oh yeah I'm the red guy
okay I'm either guests day or Conan yeah
what's that
yeah that's my third guest dare I yeah I
don't know and that's a I think I'm
Gramps
or maybe you're Gramps you know we're
gonna find out we'll find out we're
gonna find uh huh sir turbo I don't know
how to say that turbo net torrent says
hello Conan avatar is too accurate I
agree all right I'm definitely right
wait wait well so when the ghost gets
close when Lambert the ghost gets close
you'll vibrate more you'll vibrate more
and I dragged your body some wow I'm
gonna revive her come come get my back
oh oh my god how do I get up you guys
are all gonna go dad like you all do
it's vibrating like crazy but I'm still
I know me too
she's right next to me somebody this
game was like made somebody revive oh
just pick one everyone the pink one is
or barf or pick witness to your stinky
Judi frutti tutti frutti or stinky socks
Oh
tutti frutti clearly - oh my god that's
the worst one yet what we're doing is
please Judd get these jelly bellies
we're playing bean boozled the jelly
bellies either taste delicious or taste
disgusting you don't know - you try them
this one was tutti frutti or stinky
socks it smells so bad
wait you got to smell it
that's worse than sticking violence on
this road alright pay your mouth oh [ __ ]
that's by far the worst it's so bad
my hand smells it smells it smells like
I mean it smells like CDs I got these
socks looked at for my dirty socks that
have been in a dirty bag
you know I could really smell the diary
all right I feel like I should do
because here is this ROP your mouth in
case this might be toothpaste so you
don't have to do one you're the ghost I
know but I feel like it's fair whatever
this is is disgusting it's orange
oh it's or it oh you got barf oh it
tastes like what's this that's buttered
popcorn or rotten egg here we go I'm
going all right what should i do what
should i do skunk spray or licorice yeah
whatever you do not the barf one
licorice hey wait somebody Oh
here's actually a real thing how this
guy no you know it's weird when you're
an adult it's weird to make new friends
yeah we're not friends um professional
contacts please but which so I made a
new friend just like a weeks ago and
then I found out ah then you just have a
sense of smell but I don't know how to I
really want to ask me questions about it
but I heard it secondhand and I don't
know how to bring it up to him because
it's like kind of cool because you can
just part as much as you want as long as
it's quiet but and it's like I haven't
worried about how I smell anyway but it
but it's also I'm sure something he's
very and every time I put my hand into
my face it smells like dirty socks by
the way so I wish I had no smell
how do I bring it up married napkin
because there is barf jelly bean
business yeah I'm happy here you can
this is what this is how you casually
bring it up you say you eat something
you go to some L weird here smell it and
see it up so I just squeeze the water so
now it looks like Peter Pan's Fairbanks
thank you no no it's next wait I don't
want to say he smells cuz then I'm sure
that's like his biggest fear say it
smells in here do you smell that next
time you are aware for something oh
right yeah it's weird go liar it'd be
like you freak get out I wonder what can
we get a rematch turning castmates
against each other yeah we have a
constant battle she scares me all the
time really do you guys on the set of
teachers which airs at 10:30 every
Wednesday night TV Land like to prank
each other I mean aside from clogging
your own toilet other pranks that you
guys play yeah I like to scare colleton
and public restrooms yeah it's not funny
really think about it it's when you have
to go to the bathroom wait for her like
I wait till she's done I hear a zip and
then I scare her right after the zip
yeah so now is it like zip beat John or
zip to jump or usually why switch it up
but I like you know yeah I bet her what
are we talking about like she when she
comes out you punch her in the face real
Martin she'll either stick her hand
under or she'll jump out at me I grab
her ankles so can I now say that I
started going to the bathroom and doing
this like okay okay who's there because
I got so professionally no one's there
and she's in an airport by herself I
always do it in like a tower in our
writers room or on set so I don't do it
in like your locations like airports
sure she's very quiet like a ghost have
you but have you adapted you know humans
are creatures of evolution we adapt to
any situation
do you now just crap superfast why are
you adapting she's trying to make you a
better more perfect killing me yeah
thank you and you are what it is
fine whatever but you know what I'm
saying it's not even my bowels but I now
scream and shorter increments okay lady
stop screams and now it's like okay more
like a bird you know I'm just I'm doing
a jelly bean now fire and it's Bart
shoots dead immediately thing is still
vibrating by the way barf great so she's
over here okay just hold it down for
God's sakes order up
remind me never to go fighting the the
paranormal with you guys she's somewhere
she's somewhere I feel like it's a group
you guys can really you don't have save
like surround him and kill him you know
there's so many of you
we've gone ghost hunting together what
are your let's say you're a super team
and you're our super team the katydids
but let's say you are a different super
team what are your superpowers slash
special skills so you're more of a scout
I am upset at us I mean I feel like this
shouldn't go in the special skills
section of my resume I wouldn't put it
there I would not hire you for this
Rihanna's shine like a diamond go go
we're on a shine bright like a diamond
it's a port that's what I'm talking
about okay NYC just got here this
morning that's awesome time for that I'm
gonna put a newt nerd girl in my mouth
don't she's got it singing and being a
ghost
those are my two skills I could be a
Samana I've got another barf man
no I'm grating the barbed cheese tastes
like rotten pizza oh the barf was so
nasty so what is this TV show and where
can I find it it's yours
you can watch the pilot on Hulu iTunes
on demand yeah that's tvline.com slash
slash slash teachers follow them at
teachers series at Facebook and Twitter
and yeah we talked about this a little
bit but you guys the first episode
broadcast last Wednesday premiere you
went back to Chicago with Sharna Halpern
improv legend yes and so like what's
next now that's the season goes what do
you guys cuz you guys have shot all the
episodes right yeah right so are you
guys performing now or what are you
doing writing the next season are you
just eating barf Jelly Bellies like me
wasting my life in this room yeah
wearing ironic t-shirts and just
questioning the everyday you look in the
mirror like what are you doing with your
life yeah that's how we started okay
cool yeah no we are we are working a
little bit we got some scripts for
season two we haven't gotten a series
order but we've we've been working on it
gotta be prepared man that's cool so
people live in LA where's the next time
that can come see you live it would be
January 30th at 1 p.m. at Rio La awesome
January 3rd is in the past you need a
time machine and you don't want to talk
of paradoxes that's all we're doing a
walk a watching talk that's gonna show
some episodes of teachers that have been
unaired and then whoa it's like a live
kind of commentary situation yeah
whoa now do you guys just throw out fake
facts cuz I would totally do that
just me like yeah this person died and I
don't know like this unset and like when
I live tweet I just like to JK Kayla do
someone I take my place and I'll join
the peanut gallery Thomas all I'm saying
is we gotta bust out these two
before the end of the day yeah you gotta
get it get americolor at the plus okay
somebody's asking one of you be my mom
George I think the answer is yes who
wants to be that person's mom anyway I'm
cool
we never finish the teacher thing whoo
best teachers you guys have had funniest
mr. wood phone history teacher
please take Lambert down I just want to
say I found my calling and it's a
because it okay if I T all right good
yeah no okay cool this is really fun
this is great this is my favorite thing
ever we've ever I know she's coming for
me my favorite game I can feel her I
feel oh all right Tom is going down I
know where she is I know where she's
dragging me I'll provide me oh she's
coming at you yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
house alright well now we're busting
open all right we're doing it ladies
everyone gets a spoiled milk and coconut
no lenger fishy one you know you're a
chance okay yeah I mean do you want I'll
do it is this lady going to the world
champion yeah yeah it's real bad that's
is that the worst one I think I might
know far Garf was really bad I spoiled
the Telegraph I really yeah really good
tastes like barf Oh unbelievable
Jesus Christ all right one more game for
the dead vision strawberry look I'm
actually shaking does someone want to be
the gold yeah switch it up a killer get
in here yeah freed you want to complain
that was the spoiled milk was the worst
that was actually really bad I'm not
even kidding there's like that's like
not even funny
perfect that's what you want so I don't
do anything I just so you're just
looking on here there's nothing
depressed just bump into people now this
is the last one we haven't tried is dead
fish
dead fish and strawberry banana smoothie
right there it's dead it's not dead
fishy and strawberry I think the person
just wrote it that's right this is for
all the Jelly Bellies guys the rotten
milk was really really bad house gnarly
Oh
oh really fancy oh yeah this is also
hard this is our last game is the
hardest level Oh what I I think the
electricity bills gonna be very hot very
high alright look on the screen there
you have to do something I need it's a
fixer-upper but this is more of a home
gym I think Oh
[Music]
loser has to beat the has to eat the
whole tube dark necromancy I don't think
that's a good idea
we'll see we'll take it as it comes I'll
remember ladies your five oh yeah Oh get
up get them oh and now it's kind of hard
cuz you're floating around ghosts do you
float over the collagen do you float
over the things or do you get these
treadmills are impossible that's a new
character she-she's workshopping oh wait
oh oh wait she's on the treadmill she's
not the chozo can you visit treadmill my
lights about to die just leave me for
dead
leave my body to rot teamwork I don't
you Bach is die
what am I just scream diary I need I
need I need the thank you one person
left you psychopath yes psychopath
order this dry you Friedman's dead body
yes thank you I gotta get off this
[ __ ] treadmill babes apt amicus yes
get away from me check you're dragging
dead Freeman's dead body I can't enjoy
that oh my god please oh man I'm so
close I'm gonna do the dead fish I'm
sorry
this is like Jonestown compound all
right you guys want to try this to a
dead fish our strawberry banana smoothie
all ready one two three
yes booty oh my god so bad
I got it so bad you would even bad locks
your whole life yeah this is where we
find out yeah oh my god cut to usual
suspects montage of yeah well you know
what that's a great note to end on haha
guys thank you so much for joining us
the cast of teachers Katie Collett and
Katherine ray Thomas Kate Lambert Katie
O'Brien katefreeman and Caitlin Barlow
teachers is on every Wednesday night at
10:30 9:30 central on TV land you can
see old episodes of which there's only
one so far so good to start it start
watching now you only got one to catch
up on
on Hulu and tvline.com and follow at the
teachers series on Facebook and Twitter
and they'll do it thank you so much if
you need a ghost hunting I think you
know who to call these ladies we'll see
you guys next week
you